vamos a hablar de un problema típico de
probabilidad llamado el problema de
montijo y se llama montijo el porqué
montijo le era un programa de televisión
en el cual se hacía un trato muy
parecido a este problema que vamos a ver
así que imagínate tú en el foro tú eres
el participante y enfrente de ti hay
tres cortinas entonces el conductor te
presenta las tres cortinas esta es la
cortina número uno la cortina número dos
y la cortina número tres y te dicen que
bajo una de estas tres cortinas hay un
premio maravilloso algo que tú siempre
has querido el coche de tus sueños unas
vacaciones una mansión en parís o la
cantidad de dinero de la persona más
rica del mundo mientras que las otras
dos hay un premio que tú nunca has
querido una cabra de mascota una ostra
un chicle masticado un pisapapeles o lo
que sea que nunca habías querido y
entonces lo que tú tienes que hacer es
encontrar cuál es el premio ganador y
entonces el conductor te dice cuál de
estas tres cortinas elegiría
así que voy a suponer que tú eliges la
puerta número 1 o la catafixia número 1
es la cortina número 1 y bueno en este
programa de montijo lo que hacían era
poner lo más interesante no te enseñaban
lo que había en la cortina número 1 pero
lo que sí hacían era enseñarles lo que
había en una de estas otras dos cortinas
y claramente lo que hacían para
mantenerlo más interesante y con más
rating pues lo que hacen es enseñarte el
premio que no es el correcto así que
imagínate que abre en la cortina número
3 y en la cortina número 3 te enseñan
que había una fabulosa cabra y después
te preguntaban quieres cambiar tú a la
cortina número 2 es decir quieres hacer
un cambio en tu elección todavía puedes
hacerlo estás a tiempo piénsalo bien y
bueno entonces la pregunta va a ser
realmente importa cambiar un 9 cortina
es decir tú te puedes mantener con tus
pantalones y decir yo quiero quedarme
con la cortina número 1 o tal vez te
convendría cambiar la cortina número 2
es justo lo que yo me estoy preguntando
en esta ocasión y bueno te puedo
encargar que pases en este momento el
vídeo que no hagas nada más que pienses
en cuál la respuesta correcta por qué
y ahora voy a solucionar este problema
así que en este momento yo estoy
suponiendo que ya pausas del vídeo
anteriormente y que ya tienes una idea o
una opinión acerca de esto por lo tanto
voy a resolver el problema y vamos a
trabajar un poco bueno para resolver
este acertijo vamos a pensar en este
problema pero vamos a ver este problema
a partir de los creadores del show
porque al final recuerda que los que
crearon este espectáculo saben dónde
está la otra cabra y dónde está el
premio mayor y vamos a suponer que el
premio mayor es decir todo lo mejor está
en la cortina número 2 vamos a suponer
que el premio mayor es un automóvil en
esta ocasión recuerda que en la cortina
número 3 y el abrimos y había una cabra
y en la cortina número 1 vamos a suponer
que también hay otra cabra y bueno
recuerda que el participante no sabe
todo esto esto lo saben los creadores
del espectáculo sin embargo el
participante había escogido la cortina
número 1 y si te das cuenta no puede
enseñarnos lo que hay en la cortina
número 2 porque ahí está el automóvil
por lo tanto cuando nos enseñan la
primera cortina nos van a enseñar la
cabra qué bien la cortina número 3
y bueno and date cuenta que si entonces
a ti te enseñaba en la puerta número dos
realmente no había diferencia en cuál de
las otras dos puertas se enseñaran
porque las otras dos tenían una cabra y
bueno si el participante inicialmente
elegía la puerta número 3 entonces deben
enseñar la puerta número 1 la cual tenía
una cabra bueno ahora con todo esto
sería muy bueno pensar en las
probabilidades de que ganemos este juego
entonces vamos a escribirlo tenemos dos
posibles escenarios el primer escenario
vamos a decir que es cuando no cambias
de cortina no cambias de cortina
entonces cuál es la probabilidad de
ganar entonces no cambia si vamos a
calcular primeramente la probabilidad de
ganar de obtener el mejor premio que
nunca has pensado en toda tu vida por lo
tanto cuál es la probabilidad de ganar
bueno pues si te das cuenta es la
probabilidad inicial es decir cómo
decidiste mantener tu decisión por lo
tanto la probabilidad de ganar es de un
tercio pues solamente había una cortina
correcta de tres posibles y la
probabilidad de perder bueno pues son
las otras dos cortinas que tienen los
premios malos por lo tanto son dos
tercios la probabilidad de perder y ya
acabamos con nuestro 1er
que es cuando no cambias de estrategia
ahora vamos a ver el segundo escenario
que es cuando siempre cambias de cortina
es decir cuando tú en tu siguiente paso
decides cambiar de cortina primero
calculemos cuál es la probabilidad de
ganar entonces la probabilidad de ganar
quién va a ser vamos a ver los casos con
calma qué va a pasar si tú inicialmente
elegiste la cortina número uno bueno
entonces te van a enseñar la cortina
número tres y por lo tanto cuando tú
decides cambiar qué crees te vas a
obtener el automóvil es decir vas a
ganar el premio que siempre quisiste
haber tú escogiste la cortina número uno
y te tienen que enseñar una cortina que
no tenga el premio correcto por lo tanto
te enseñan la cortina número tres y
cuando tú decides cambiar qué crees
cambias de la cortina mala a la cortina
buena y entonces le das el automóvil
vamos a escribirlo por acá a ver en el
paso número 1 inicialmente tú escoges
una cortina incorrecta y en el paso
número 2 si tú decides siempre cambiar
por lo tanto siempre vas a ganar si
inicialmente escoges mal
siempre cambiar esto quiere decir que
siempre vas a ganar vamos a pensar en el
otro caso supongamos que escogiste
inicialmente la cortina número 3 y qué
va a pasar pues te enseñan la cortina
número 1 y cuando tú decides cambiar qué
crees te llevas otra vez el automóvil
por lo tanto se sigue cumpliendo esta
regla y siempre ganas y ya con esto
tenemos una idea de cuánto es la
probabilidad la probabilidad es dos
tercios es decir cuál es la probabilidad
de que inicialmente hayamos elegido mal
y como hay dos cortinas malas entonces
la probabilidad es dos tercios ahora
vamos a pensar qué es lo que pasa con la
probabilidad de perder si nos fijamos en
la probabilidad de perder cuál es la
forma de que podamos perder bueno para
perder tendría que pasar lo siguiente en
el primer paso que hayamos escogido
correcto así que vamos a escribir el
primer paso inicialmente es [ __ ] la
cortina correcta y después nos enseñan
una de las dos cortinas la cual tiene
una cabra por lo tanto en el segundo
paso nos enseñan una de las cortinas que
no tiene un premio correcto y en el
tercer paso tú decides cambiar porque
siempre decides cambiar y por lo tanto
pierdes y esto se oye muy mal pero vamos
a calcularlo en probar
cuál es la probabilidad de que
inicialmente tú escojas bien bueno pues
la probabilidad de que inicialmente
escojas bien es un tercio porque
solamente hay una cortina correcta con
el automóvil de tres que hay y sé que
estos son un poco esotérico pero
fijémonos en lo que calculamos la
probabilidad la probabilidad cuando no
cambias es de un tercio para que ganes
mientras que la probabilidad cuando
siempre cambias es de dos tercios de que
ganes otra forma de verlo sería que
cuando tú inicialmente eliges una de las
cortinas solamente tienes una
probabilidad de un tercio de que
realmente esté el premio mayor ahí
mientras que hay dos tercios de
probabilidad de que el premio esté en
otra de las dos cortinas y lo estamos
viendo justo aquí así que espero que
hayas disfrutado este vídeo